and i just wonder first of all
we're told that president putin is
preparing or asked his generals to
prepare the next stage of this offensive
what do you think it will involve
thank you for having me and i have first
to confess that i saw the previous
portion about the parliament with envy
you have debates real debates in the
parliament
long forgotten in russia
and that is one of the reasons why
putin regime is doomed in long run but
in short run
they feel pain from
the western supplies
including
from the great britain
but especially the new supplies of the
long-range weapons
from america
and that should be continued because if
he says it publicly
that it hurts
that should be continued and that is
probably the shortest
way to end the war yeah i mean do you
think that he will continue to
weaponize energy supplies and food
supplies also with grain in ukraine do
you think that
he will continue to do that
he will do everything including
weaponizing uh the foods and if he could
in medicine
in russia in inside he is now
weaponizing
the education process which is probably
which means harm for future generations
probably of russians
he will go as far as the west allows him
to do
and the best answer to all of that
are those weapons of the long range
and
it's it's it's a little bit depressing
that while he is weaponizing everything
including food and gas
that means probably quote
i know that today it probably sounds
ironic
for you
that cold is bad but
yes it would be bad in uh in the winter
time
that the west is under weaponizing steel
under weaponizing ukraine ukraine should
be weaponized
to an extent to
uh stop and repel
the uh invasion
do you think that nato will eventually
have to use its military power in a
in a bigger way to turn the tide in this
war
i think no need for that uh it was
kind of debatable decision from the very
beginning especially
telling all the time we will not do that
we will not do that i mean that to my
mind was absolutely wrong
strategy
and tactic
and
under weaponizing
ukraine when he
weaponizes everything
possible
is also a debatable uh or rather a
mistake to my mind
but there is no need for such measures
like
direct
nato
military engagement enough is
i mean the the defense minister
said yesterday clearly and loudly that
it's long-range artillery and
missile systems that changes uh the
situation on the front
do it i mean as far as i know as far as
i understand
america supplies only four of those
systems
but supply 40 of those systems and no
need for nato engagement he is not as
a
scary uh
in real terms
as it is he is painted i mean there is a
lot of misconception in the west and of
course he will not
be suicidal
if he is uh defeated uh in ukraine
he lived with that he was uh
ruling russia for 14 years 15 years
actually
before uh even uh
2014 when he took
the crimea
in its uh original borders russia in its
regional borders and ukraine and in
regional borders and it was okay so it's
nothing new for him and he will not be
cornered if
uh the ukrainians with the nato help but
not necessarily direct engagement would
just return to the situation everyone
will be in its borders what's wrong with
this
yeah okay well listen we've run out of
time but mr kosarev we appreciate your
time on the program and
it's important we give this time to the
story in ukraine thank you very much
indeed for being with us appreciate your
time